is this love agent Romanoff love is for
children I owe him the debt
tell me
before I worked for shield I well I made
a name for myself I have a very specific
skill set I didn't care who I used it
for or on I got on shields radar in a
bad way agent Barton was sent to kill me
he made a different call
and what will you do if I vow to spare
him not let you out I don't know but I
like this your world in the balance and
you bargain for one man regimes fall
every day I tend not to weep over that
in Russian where I was and was how you
know it's really not that complicated I
got red in my ledger I'd like to wipe it
out
can you
can he wipe out that much red Dre coughs
daughter são Paulo the hospital fire
Barton told me everything the ledger is
dripping it's gushing red and you think
saving a man no more virtuous than
yourself will change anything this is
the basest sentimentality this is a
child of Prayer pathetic you lie and
kill in the service of liars and killers
[Music]
you pretend to be separate to have your
own code something that makes up for the
horrors but they are part of you
and they will never go away they won't
touch Barton not until I make him kill
you slowly intimately in every way he
knows you fear and then he'll wake just
long enough to see his good work and
when he screams our split his skull this
is my bargain you mewling quim your
monster so banner that's your play what
Loki means to unleash the Hulk keep
banner in the lab I'm on my way son Thor
is awful
thank you for your cooperation
you